er ist jung er ist er ist urban
zumindest für zdf verhältnisse genau ihn
braucht die csu jetzt image consulting
profil optimizer
und fand heraus wir drehen hier ein
imagefilm um aus der csu eine moderne
urbane partei zu machen kommt große
lektion haben sie aus einer großstadt
dahin waren dort dann müssen sie bitten
aus dem bild zu gehen die bilder dürfen
nicht on air gehen die bilder dürfen
nicht on air gehen vielleicht als
kleiner kompromiss schauen sie doch mal
etwas moderner so als würden sie die
grünen wählen es geht zuerst den tisch
müssten wir nicht komplett räumen hier
ne
[Musik]
uns hätte gerne einen aperol spritz
bitte ja die kosten selber holen ich
hätte ein paar vorschläge für moderne
slogans die man vielleicht zusammen in
die kamera sagt csu so sehen sieger aus
natürlich hat mich verlesen ein csu so
sahen sieger aus das ist der stoff
bayern ohne csu ist wie oktoberfest ohne
kotzen was kann die csu machen um so ein
bisschen obama zu werden auch für die
jüngeren ansprechenden interessiert mir
die sonne
ich bin ja mehrere birte anton hofreiter
ist genauso gegen den freihandel wie
donald trump es ist ja auch kein wunder
sie haben denselben friseur man es eher
werden damen und ihr seid jung
ihr seid hipp was macht ihr hier wir
wollten wieder aus ja weil einfach nur
der kerl ist der schnee fiel war er
allein seid ihr zufrieden mit der rede
ja wohl was hat euch gut gefallen
es ist sogar das sommersemester
heiligabend dem 14
aber es hat uns gut gefallen hat das ist
ein altes iphone modell tauschen sich
gegen das neue heraus bitte wie sieht
das denn sonst aus alles kann einfach so
ans ohr halten vielleicht so ein
bisschen ein bisschen über junge themen
reden das was im club waren gestern war
gestern im club
natürlich bin ich gespannt welche
schwerpunktthema hält so auch das ist
alles nicht hätten genug schwerpunkt
themen einfach nur sagen alles frisch
hier
liga alles recht locker dicke dinger ja
alles prächtiger glückwunsch schon mal
selber zum erfolgreichen wahlkampf
leider nur erfolgreich für die afg
bisher finde ich nicht wenn ihr mal
endlich anfangen würde mitzuhelfen
wer weiß vielleicht aber sie drehten die
spd ein dass man sich die falsche partei
mit helfen ja klar dafür bin ich doch
hier und zwar mit meinem motivierenden
fresh und hippen open imagefilm
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin wieder hier vorgestern im klub
alles völlig egal was einst mit der csu